- [Interviewer] What do
you think you get from it;
just that it's fun?
That it's exciting?
That it's lucrative?
- I love to have sex.
- [Interviewer] Oh you like to have sex?
- Yeah, I do.
- That doesn't hurt.
- I love to suck dick.
I love my pussy.
Right?
(chuckling)
- [Interviewer] All right, Princess.
- Hi.
- Hi, welcome back.
It's been six months or
more since we talked last.
What's new in your life?
Has anything changed?
- I'm staying with a client.
I'm actually just trying
to do a lot better
for myself right now.
- [Interviewer] Are you still using drugs?
- Of course.
- [Interviewer] And when
you say stay with a client,
he allows you to see other clients?
- Most of the time.
Sometimes he gets angry jealous though.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You know, but that's all right.
That's all right, I let him you know.
But yeah, I still see other people.
Yeah, I still date normally.
I'm in charge.
- [Interviewer] I saw the dynamics
of your relationship with him.
You're clearly in charge
of that relationship.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And so,
with that relationship
we won't divulge who it was,
what is that relationship like?
- It's actually pretty cool.
- [Interviewer] Is it boyfriend
girlfriend type thing,
or is it?
- Well sometimes I got pretend like it is,
because he thinks it is.
You know, but I have friends
and they'll call him, they'll
tell him straight to his face
like you're a trick, you know?
He gets a little upset with that.
Sometimes I tell him you know
just what he wants to hear.
- [Interviewer] Does he see
other ladies on the side?
- Well he does.
He does, don't get me wrong.
- [Interviewer] You're both
kind of straying a bit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And he's generally good to you?
- Mm-hm yeah he's great.
For the most part.
- [Interviewer] That's good.
So where's your life stand now?
Your family knows you're out here.
And you're very open with them--
- Yeah very.
- about your situation and
what you're doing and all that.
- I actually showed them the first one.
- Oh you did, the first video?
- Yeah I sent a link to them.
- How did they react to that?
- Essentially they didn't even reply.
(laughing)
- They didn't reply, but I
wanted them to know, you know.
- Right, nothing you
are doing would surprise
them it sounds like.
- No, they already knew.
They come visit me.
- [Interviewer] They told you what.
- Actually my dad just came
and visited me not long ago.
- [Interviewer] Where are you from?
Where are they from?
You don't have to say if
you don't want to say.
- Okay.
- Yeah you don't have to.
- Thank you.
- I'm sorry.
- It's a long way away, far.
- It's not L.A.?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
Have you been arrested for this?
- No.
- [Interviewer] You've
never been arrested?
- No, well I've never been
arrested for prostituting.
- [Interviewer] You're one of
the flashiest girls out there.
I'm surprised.
- I believe in karma a lot
so I try not to do anything
that will bring anything bad to me,
any worse than what already happens.
So I try to stick to myself,
and just not do anything wrong.
You know I try not to give
then a reason to stop me.
- [Interviewer] I mean do
you view what you're doing
for these men as you're just--
- I view it as my work.
- [Interviewer] I know
but it's also something
that's therapeutic almost for them?
- Yeah it could be therapeutic for me too.
- For you too?
- Uh huh.
- [Interviewer] How's that?
You mean it helps you buy
the things you need to buy?
- Oh yes definitely.
- Yeah.
Are there other therapeutic
things about it?
- Yeah there are there therapeutic things
about it to be honest.
- [Interviewer] Which would be like what?
- You know different people to talk to,
things to go do,
like presents, exciting things.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, they're nice to you,
are they good to you gifts
and things like that?
- Uh huh.
- [Interviewer] When was the last time
you actually had a boyfriend of your own?
- High school.
And this lifestyle gets in the
way of that of course, right?
- Yeah, well actually hold up.
Let me rewind.
I wouldn't call him my boyfriend
that's why I didn't say it.
For like the last four
or five years of my life,
I met him, he called me
I had an ad posted online
and he called me off online.
The first day he moved
me into the mansion.
It was a trick.
But I lived with him for the last
four or five years of my
life before I came here.
Well, I came here for him.
But he put his hands on me
for the first time so I left.
- [Interviewer] So he's
like a sugar daddy kinda of?
- Yeah, sugar daddy.
Good one, like a multi-millionaire.
He was a good one.
- [Interviewer] Are those
relationships kind of--
- Well, after five
years of living with him
he put his hands on me for the first time,
but he was real fucked up.
He wanted me to suck his dick,
but I didn't want to because
he had been up for days.
I mean he was seeing another
girl, and he didn't want
to put a condom on.
So I didn't suck his dick
and he got real angry.
Had like a martin glass like this he boom
smashed this mother fucker in my leg,
tackles me off the bed
and starts kicking me.
He says he doesn't know
like he blacked out,
but I ran out of the hotel
over Hyatt Regency by LAX.
I ran out of there with a
belly shirt and bikini bottoms,
and glass just coming out of my legs
just gushing down my leg,
and from there, I knew no one here.
I had just gotten here.
My luggage was there, my phone was there.
The one person I knew was the.
- [Interviewer] I can take that out.
- Thank you, I shouldn't day that.
- [Interviewer] Don't worry
about it, I can take it out.
The one person I knew
was the person I was buying drugs from.
- [Interviewer] So you've
been here ever since?
- Yeah and that's how I
started walking the streets.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you've
been here how many years?
- Almost two now.
- [Interviewer] And do you
see, do you have a plan
to get out of this situation or this life?
- I plan to get clean soon.
- [Interviewer] You've been clean before?
- Yeah, when I to here I was clean.
- [Interviewer] And
the drugs you are using
are kind of an assortment of all of them?
- Yeah they're fucking me up.
They're fucking my nerve
system up, big time.
- [Interviewer] You're
using them all, right?
- Yeah.
Which one is your favorite?
- Uh heroin or crack.
I like it.
- [Interviewer] What are the
differences between heroin,
crack and crystal meth?
- Heroin is a downer it's
an opiate you fall asleep.
Crystal meth or cocaine?
- [Interviewer] All three,
just give me a quick.
- Crystal Meth is like under
your kitchen sink cabinet.
It's all horrible stuff, I think.
It's supposed to make you
horny, but it makes you horny.
(laughing)
Cocaine, cocaine crack
it's cocaine rocked up.
That's a speed up, keeps you awake.
- [Interviewer] How often
do you use, like every day?
- Every day.
- [Interviewer] Did you
kind of need it to do this?
- Yeah, I needed to relax.
- [Interviewer] Just to do
this with the guys and so on?
- Oh yeah I don't want
to do it sober no, no.
I probably could, but it
easier to deal with it on meth.
- [Interviewer] Have you ever considered
working witH a pimp?
- Yeah I have in the past.
- [Interviewer] You've worked with pimps?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And tell me the difference
in with and without pimp.
- With it it's fun with one, you know?
You get to have a good time
with the person you like.
They look out they got your back,
so you never got to worry about nothing.
If they're a good one they're a good one.
They're how a pimp is supposed to be.
I like that, I prefer that.
But if they're bad one then
they're just a pretend pimp.
Fuck that.
You got no money just think of that.
- [Interviewer] But
that's what I'm saying,
if a pimp is taking all
you money what's the upside
of that relationship?
- Mostly they're just
thinking about themselves.
They don't give a fuck.
- [Interviewer] But you
kind of expressed that
it was kind of actually
good to be with a good pimp.
- Yeah if it's a good one,
how a pimp is supposed to be,
a real pimp, then fuck yeah.
- [Interviewer] Because
he treats you really well?
- Yeah they buy you everything.
You got everything you need.
And you ain't got to manage no money.
You ain't got to deal with nothing.
You just got everything you
need, do whatever you want.
- [Interviewer] So I
guess what you're saying
is some are great and some are--
- Yeah, a real pimp is a good one.
- [Interviewer] Some know
how to treat their ladies
and others don't.
- Yeah, some know how to do it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that makes sense.
- More so not than there
are the ones that do,
but there are ones that do.
- [Interviewer] Where did
you first get the idea
to do this as a line of work?
As a way to make money.
- [Princess] I never walked
but I would post on back page.
You know I'd post on back page.
You get $200 an hour
you get so much for
freaky stuff, you know.
I had this guy paying me
$500 bucks all I would
do is lay down, he would come on top
of me with his easy jack-off.
All he wanted to do was come on my face.
And it was 10 minutes and
I got like $500 bucks.
Right, that's not bad?
And he wiped it off and cleaned it for me
with baby wipes after.
(chuckling)
Yep, that was a good one,
and then he'd give me
like maybe a hundred,
two hundred more just to video it.
- [Interviewer] So you've
done all kinds if crazy stuff.
- [Princess] Me and this guy
have made like 20 videos.
- Really?
- Mm-hm.
- [Interviewer] And what
happens with those videos?
- [Princess] Oh they
just stay on our phones.
- [Interviewer] Yeah that's it.
- [Princess] Sometimes
I show them to people.
(chuckling)
I got a bunch of great pictures.
- [Interviewer] I'll bet you do.
- [Princess] I do, I love pictures.
- [Interviewer] Don't lose your phone.
- [Princess] I know right.
Where is my phone?
He's got my phone.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] Does this line of work
ever get you depressed
sometimes, get you down?
- [Princess] Oh yeah.
Yeah when you think you're
pregnant oh that's a scare.
That just happened to me to long ago.
- [Interviewer] Do you do this
sometimes without condoms?
- Sometimes.
- Yep
- Sometimes you're not expecting to,
but you just don't put one on and.
If it's a regular, you know,
one that you see all the time
and you know they're good,
and like once in a blue moon
he don't want to, I'll be down.
(chuckling)
I'll be down.
But that's very few, I got to
know you very fucking well.
And even that, I don't even want to,
I pull the condom out, I
got the condom on the bed,
they just did it without it,
and fuck I can't do nothing about it.
- [Interviewer] Have you ever had diseases
or anything like that?
- Yeah I have.
Easy ones that you just go to the doctor
and get medicine and they go away.
- [Interviewer] Right,
what's the worst thing
about doing this as a career?
- Police.
I've been arrested for a bunch of stuff,
and been in a bunch of trouble.
It's the worst place in the world.
I've never been arrested here though.
- [Interviewer] That's right
you said you've never been
arrested for prostitution, right?
- No never for prostitution.
- [Interviewer] But other stuff?
- Yeah.
- Drugs, DUI, stuff like that you know.
- [Interviewer] Do you
enjoy what you're doing?
- Kind of, I kind of do I'm not gonna lie.
Should I lie?
- No.
- No?
- Okay.
- The truth is truth.
- Okay, I'm all for it.
(laughing)
- You enjoy it?
- I do.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think you gain self esteem
from it in the way the guys--
- No I already have that.
- [Interviewer] You had that
before you even started?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think you get from it?
That it's fun?
That's it's lucrative?
Thar it's exciting?
- I love to have sex.
- [Interviewer] You like to have sex?
- Yeah, I do.
- [Interviewer] That doesn't hurt.
- I love to suck dick.
I love my pussy.
Right?
(chuckling)
I don't want to get too explicit.
- [Interviewer] No you can get
as explicit as you like here.
- Oh yeah?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- You can tell me anything you want.
- Okay, cool I like that.
- [Interviewer] What's the
kinkiest craziest thing
you've had a customer do with you?
You mentioned something
with this gentleman.
- Oh yeah, he's the only person
I let fuck me in my butt.
I had just started that,
that's a new thing.
(chuckling)
That won't be on the internet, right?
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] I may have
to pay you etra for that one.
- Okay I'll take that I guess.
- [Interviewer] But do
you consider yourself
more of an escort or a prostitute?
- Escort.
Okay well there you go.
Then you're an escort.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
So you've moved up.
- I started up, I moved down actually.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah.
- Oh I see.
- I never walked the street before.
And before that I danced.
- [Interviewer] Oh so you were a stripper?
- Yeah I was a stripper.
- [Interviewer] Oh I see, and
how does this compare to--
- Way more money.
- [Interviewer] This is more money?
- Less work.
I might be getting fat now but.
(chuckling)
Because dancing keeps you
really good in shape you know?
- Yeah.
- Fuck yeah.
- [Princess] I'm about to put
a pole in where I'm staying.
I'm about to have them
put a pole in for me.
- [Interviewer] Just for exercise?
- [Princess] Yep just so
I can play in it, yep.
I can do some bad-ass tricks.
- [Interviewer] All right Princess.
Thank you so much of talking to me.
- Thank you.
Thank you.